so betrayal is a very tough thing and
it's part of giving trust is the odds
are you will be betrayed at some point
in time so so getting good at dealing
with betrayal is a really important
thing and I think it starts with
realizing that you have joint ventured
the betrayal you've had a part to do
with it it could be that you trusted
when you shouldn't have trusted you
didn't think about whether the person
had high character was competent and had
the authority and therefore shame on you
we don't like to take responsibility for
that but I think if you step back and
say how did I participate in this I
think that gives you insight and a sort
of the first ability to start
approaching it in a way that allows you
to heal because that's really what you
want to do in a betrayal is you want to
heal as fast as you can
and so I think it really helps to do
that so anytime you're betrayed you feel
alone if you're like why me you have the
poor Me's and you feel like you've been
attacked and it's all unfair and
everything I think if you if you step
back and say everybody's been betrayed
everybody knows what this feels like
and people get over it and therefore I'm
not alone in this and I can learn from
other people and this too will pass so
sometimes when you're in the midst of it
and you're dealing with it and it's
acute it feels like it's all you can
think about you wake up in the middle of
the night it's the first thing on your
mind when you start your day it stays
with you throughout the day and you
start to marinate in it and I think it's
really helpful to step back and say this
has happened to other people before and
therefore I will get through this so
sometimes people betray us and it's not
that serious they didn't deliver a
project on time or on budget or they
didn't get the report done right or they
didn't double-check their spelling or
their all kinds of levels of betrayal
and some of them really are just fumbles
stumbles poor judgment or whatever
others are really very serious where
somebody has cheated you or told a lie
or spread gossip or something like that
so I think you have to you have to sort
of calibrate what is the nature of
this betrayal if it is one of the former
I think you can step in and say we need
to come to an understanding so this
doesn't happen again
many times it's really just a question
of get having clarity around things and
the betrayal is overcome if it is
something more serious than that it may
take a whole lot more work and that work
may not be worth it
in many cases it is not worth it if
somebody certain kinds of betrayal are
just not worth fixing so if you've been
betrayed there are sometimes there are
elements for example if it's just bad
information or you can fix it quickly if
it's early on in somebody's career fix
it quickly
don't let the betrayal Fester don't
allow it to go on deal with it
immediately so fix those kinds of things
quickly because otherwise they get worse
and they you may bury them for a while
only to see them raise their head in an
uglier form down the road so I think you
want to address even the beginnings of
something that feels like it might be a
betrayal even one of these minor
betrayals so this idea about being
realistic about the potential for
recovery really comes into assessing the
nature of the betrayal if it is a
serious betrayal an infidelity something
that is really attacking you at your
core many divorces happen over this kind
of thing and it's really better off that
people separate because there's no point
in trying to make something work they
just won't work within the company
framework I always say that you need to
get the wrong people off the bus there
are people in most companies that
shouldn't be there and therefore you
need to it's kind of a betrayal of them
to keep them on the bus and they're
betraying the company by staying on the
bus so I think some things you just have
to address and and move on and just say
this is a betrayal I'm not going to try
to fix so the notion of forgiveness
around betrayal is a hard one because
we're hurting we feel like we've been
violated in an important way but it's in
our own interest the worst thing to do
is to marinate in it and to allow it to
grow
and the best thing we can do is get over
the way that I've done that is I really
realize that when I'm starting to think
about the future and I'm no longer
waking up thinking about what happened
then I've actually that's a first step
towards forgiveness and so I think the
faster you can get to the future the
more likely you are to to be able to
forgive and so I always encourage people
to get on to the next project at a young
entrepreneur one time who'd had a
difficult experience and I said go put
some points on the board that's the only
way that you'll feel better is go score
some some baskets and I think it's the
same in betrayal